love it or hate it there's no question
that the Cyber Tru has divided opinions
it's going to be a Lamborghini it's
going to cost too much uh it's not a
mainstream product there's going to be a
gigantic battery I'm calling it a toy
for Elon Fanboys even Tesla's own design
team had mixed feelings about the Cyber
truck Tesla's chief designer fron Von
holdhusen said in Walter oxen's
biography of Elon Musk a majority of
people in this studio hated it they were
like you can't be serious Elon was
serious he felt he had played it safe
with the look of the model Y and wanted
to make a bold statement with a cyber
truck once every 5 to 10 years something
really special a really unusual product
comes along and we'll remember those
special moments Innovation can be
shocking new designs can be unsettling
remember when people laughed at airpods
Elon Sun Saxon once asked why doesn't
the future look like the future finally
the future will look like the the
[Applause]
future his vision for a forward-looking
design was inspired by the Lotus espr
from the James Bond film the spy who
loved me a car he admired so much that
he bought it for a million dollars and
gave it a place of honor in Tesla's
Design Studio in the Cyber trucks
engineering seem to naturally call for a
futuristic look the vehicle is made from
the same stainless steel used in
spacex's Starship so it's certainly
Tough Enough for terrestrial travel the
body panels used cars are traditionally
made out of aluminum or steel Alloys
because of their ease of use and cost
Effectiveness however Elon wondered if
another material might be better for a
durable high- Performance electric truck
this is an example of first principal
thinking challenging the status quo
breaking down assumptions to reimagine
possibilities pickup trucks haven't
changed much in appearance for decades
elon's approach was to create something
entirely new if you want to do something
radical and Innovative and and something
really special like the Cyber truck it
is extremely difficult because there's
nothing to copy I mean we dug our own
grave with cyer cyber truck in generally
probably everybody thinks great better
than
themselves despite how notoriously
difficult the metal is to work with Elon
was determined to create a stainless
steel vehicle the Cyber Tru will be
heavy but a stainless steel body can
bear some of the load enhancing its
durability and offering better
protection for passengers and if you're
having an argument with another car you
will
win
oh my God while the armor glass of the
sabber truck famously cracked a few
years ago Elon is serious about the
sabber truck being strong enough to
withstand bullets if El Capone showed up
with a Tommy Gun and emptied the entire
magazine into the car door you would
still be alive so uh you know and so
people say like well you know why'd you
make it bulletproof I'm like why
not the cypr trick uses a a special type
of cold rolled stainless steel patented
by Tesla hot rolling involves heating
steel to over 1700° F or 9 127° C making
it soft and malleable the steel is
pressed and shaped by big rollers as it
cools it shrinks causing the tiny grains
inside the steel that got stretched out
to relax back to their normal shape this
results in less Precision in the size
and finish of the final product while
hot rolled steel isn't very strong it's
good enough for things like railroad
tracks in Cold Rolling the steel is
cooled to room temperature rolling this
cooler harder steel requires
significantly more Force the intense
pressure during this process makes the
steel thinner and longer the grains
inside the steel gets stretched out in
the direction it's rolled and don't
revert back to their original state this
gives cold rolled steel its Superior
strength and a smoother finish but cold
rolled steel is also harder to bend in
shape so straight planes and sharp
angles are more practical you can't
actually stamp these body panels the
body panels would break the stamping
machine stainless steel also doesn't
need to be painted thanks to its natural
rust resistance which reduces
manufacturing costs when Franson holen
presented Elon with a full-size mockup
of the Cyber truck in July 2019 elon's
immediate response was that's it I love
it we are doing that when some members
of Tesla's design team suggested doing
some research to see how the public
would receive it Elon replied I don't do
focus groups as reported in isaacson's
book Elon explained I don't care if no
one buys it we're not doing a
traditional boring truck we can always
do that later I want to build something
that's cool like don't resist me he
pushed for a prototype in just 3 months
the world got a taste of the Cyber truck
in November 2019 where Elon announced
its expected range in pricing fast
forward 3 years later when Tesla
delivered delivered the first cyber
trucks in November 2023 thank for buying
cyber truck however its range hasn't
quite met the targets initially set at
its debut even with a range extender
pricing has also increased although
people have been eagerly anticipating
the delivery of more cyber trucks Elon
is quick to temper expectations at best
he expects 250,000 cyber trucks to come
off the assembly line a year beginning
in
2025 as the saying goes good things take
time and the cybertruck is no ordinary
vehicle the remarkable innovation of the
cybertruck requires a deep understanding
of engineering principles that's why I
recommend brillian a website and app
that helps to improve your math computer
science and data science skills
interactively and it's free for you to
try out data analysis is increasingly
crucial especially Technologies like
full self-driving brilliant's new data
analysis fundamentals course lets you
work with real data honing the skill
needed for developing Advanced machine
learning algorithms I personally
dedicate 10 minutes a day to Brilliance
logic puzzles to sharpen my analytical
thinking you can try it brilliant with a
30-day free trial by visiting
brilliant.org
newthink plus the first 200 people to
sign up via my link will get 20% off of
Premium subscription unlocking all the
courses thanks for watching for news
think I'm Cindy
pal